and if your home needs to shut out the
heat with style we have the place for
you guys stop by sunburst shutters and
window fashions the sponsors of this
segment to see what they have in store
take a look
[Music]
it is getting warmer outside so you
might be wondering how can you keep your
home cool here in las vegas so we're
shutter shopping at sunburst with john
first and foremost i love a good story
so i hear you guys have a unique one we
have a great story so the company
started our founder was a pharmaceutical
rep and he and his wife were getting
quotes on shutters for their home and
every time the shutter rep would come
and give him a shutter and do a quote
he'd look at it and kind of inspect it
and they'd leave and he'd tell his wife
i could build one better than that i
could do it better it happened like
three or four times and finally she said
okay do it and he did you know he quit
his pharmaceutical job and started some
of his shutters 40
almost 45 years ago now and his mantra
of we can do a better is what sunburst
shutters and window fashions does every
day with every customer let's talk
shutters now
what are the best ones for las vegas in
this crazy weather yeah so that the heat
is really bad on window treatments in
las vegas shutters are the perfect
product for windows in las vegas and
sunburst makes the hollywood shutter in
polywood is by far the most energy
efficient shutter so with the weather
stripping
the tight gaps the great closure the
density of the material hollywood blocks
more airflow into the house than any
other shutter up to 30 degrees of
temperature that we can reduce from
coming into your home which saves you on
energy december's actually create
pollywood sunburst shutters created
pollywood patented it and we're the only
ones that sell it there may be some
folks in town that say they have
bollywood but they really don't they
have something that's a knockoff and
doesn't have the energy efficiency or
good warranty that we have now this is
for your square window but what about
arched windows great question so there
are a couple of ways that hollywood
shutters can fit an arched window first
is a sunburst arch where each of these
louvers up top can open or you close
them automatically it's on a standard
rectangular shutter and sits right on
the top same window different option is
called a louvered arch so the louvers
run all the way to the top in one
continuous panel as opposed to two
panels with the sunburst on top now i'm
also noticing different frames shapes
and sizes as well
yeah there are a lot of frame options
that you can get some of it depends on
the window but you know you can do a
smooth craftsman style frame
large or small some of them we mount on
the outside of the window some inside
and flush with it with the wall it just
depends on your preference and some of
the window features that you might have
now i see you can put your shutters on
french doors and sliding glass doors
that's big here in las vegas yeah it's
great and you know most of the other
treatments you put on a french door are
our treatments might sway as you open
the door like a a blind or a shade but
ours is permanently attached to the door
and we do this little cutouts you can
move your handle still and it gives you
the ability to you know make that fully
operable this also gives you this is
called a divider rail which can split
the bottom panel the bottom louvers from
the top louvers in case you want a
little extra privacy there and a little
light here so this is what we do with a
slider sliding glass doors typically
used to vertical blinds kids pull them
down and then you're messed up forever
not with a shutter this is a permanent
feature it's on a track so they slide
but you can still operate the louvers to
get the light in then when you want to
close them you just close all the
louvers like this and you just roll it
back on the track i understand you guys
do have a special offer just for you
anyone that calls and says that they've
seen us on the show will give up to 500
off they've got to buy a minimum order
but call the office and they'll take
care of you
and window fashions for sponsoring that
segment to learn more all you got to do
is call
702-367-1600 or visit
sunburstlasvegas.com mention you saw
them on las vegas now and save up to 500
on a hollywood shutter offer or order
excuse me and of course minimum order is
required we'll be right back